benji his therapist dropped him his
therapist said she would no longer work
with him
what happened when benji did see his
therapist he mostly complained about his
sleeping problems organizational
problems
problems with perfectionism i've never
seen that in benji
you're a perfectionist there's no
evidence of that at work
you misunderstand what perfectionism is
though i think
what is that you
often get paralyzed of because of
indecision
as a perfectionist that is not
perfectionism
okay that is not the definition of a
perfectionist i think that benji is so
annoying
and so insincere in therapy
he never confided in the therapist he
never told her anything real
he was rehearsed he would think of what
to do and what to say
because he was treating it like a date
benji this is highly unusual that a
therapist drops you
she hasn't fully dropped me yet we're
gonna have an appointment this friday
but
she wanted me to think about the idea of
being with someone else
this sounds like the breakup of a
relationship that's really what it felt
like it really did feel a little sad to
me
she wants to see other people doesn't
that concern you
that the therapist finds you so
unbearable
i always worry about this in therap like
is this like
is this person like me is this boring am
i like you know
and then part of me is like maybe she's
really being sincere
that she thinks someone could be better
like to help me
like charles manson's therapist never
quit i mean
this is crazy quit wow
what were you telling her to make her
quit holy [ __ ]
you must be well dark it did take me a
long time to open up like i s
uh i didn't even mention the show i
think until a couple weeks ago because
i'm very she didn't ask what you did for
a living if she did
i talked around it or said i don't want
to bring that up yet
what and do you really want to change
benji or is this just a pastime for you
oh i really really want to change and i
know people think if you don't change
you don't
if you don't want to but why why i
really do i'm very
frustrated but it has to be perfect
that is an issue well i mean first of
all if you really wanted to change you
would open up to the therapist this idea
that yeah you wouldn't
be trying to finally you know i started
doing that i've taken my
like i give you an example something
i've done i was like you know what i'm
very embarrassed to be without my hat
to be in for and i've taken my hat off
in front of her
right wow
[Laughter]
movement you know what i want to quit
this session too
i i give her
you